welcome to another exciting day and uh
Workshop so far we heard mostly about
epidemic models and the spread of
viruses today we will hear from our our
social scientists about the spread of
information in social networks and we'll
see how the Dynamics are the same or
different so today we will hear a lot
about learning we're going to learn
about learning
the first speaker is Elon Lobel and I've
worked hard to convince him to give this
talk uh he said No at least twice uh but
um it's a fantastic it's a fantastic
result and it's going to set us up for
the uh talk by Suraj and Muhammad and
Andrea please go ahead thank you thank
you I mean it's a pleasure to be here
yeah I mean I mean can you present this
paper and I'm like that was my job
market paper and it didn't have gray
hair back then
and then it was like no no but I want
this paper I said I have new work he
says no this paper okay so here's a
paper uh so it's uh with people who are
my advisors back at MIT back in the
2000s and it's uh got published 11 years
ago and it's about learning networks and
since they're traveling back in time 10
years I might as well start 30 years
back at the beginning of this literature
and give you all a little context on
social learning and and what are some of
the methods and what do we call what do
we introduce here
okay so the starting point of the
literature is that people often copy the
actions of others and imagine like
products going viral you're buying I'm
buying something because I mean bought
something and a Min bot because it's
such a month buying something right or
you can think of meme stock trading
isn't like I buy GameStop because I see
every else everybody else buying
GameStop
and and economics always worries about
this issue because this kind of hard
Behavior could lead to things like asset
market bubbles right it could lead to
inefficient allocation of resources bad
decision making right we all own game
stock but but it's not worth very much
right and the stock not being properly
valued and the classical models of this
are all psychology model behavioral
models and the people are being kind of
dumb when they do this but there are
these really two important papers from
like 1992 that kick-started this
literature saying this can emerge as an
equilibrium Behavior between rational
agents and I want to walk you through
the example that they do which is going
to be the basis of everything we do here
today
so I'm gonna walk through that bits on
dining here's driver and Wells which I'm
going to call bhw here and what is the
example imagine people are coming into
town and they see two restaurants
there's a Chinese restaurant and there's
an Indian restaurant and they need to
choose one to go and let's say that one
of them is better but no one knows which
one and there's some prior maybe for
priors or maybe like slightly only full
price doesn't really matter here
and agents are going to have private
signals uh indicating where they should
go and the signal is correct with 70
probability so I'm going to discuss a
little bit more about this model in
terms of signals in the next slide but
just taking the face value here that
everybody has an IID signal but it's ID
condition on the state so if the state
is one all the signals you got a signal
saying go to this one or go to that one
and they're correct with a given
probability and again the 70 doesn't
matter here just want to make people
create and a key idea in this model is
that agent to subserve choices of others
but not their signals right I know what
A Min did because I can see him sitting
in a restaurant but I don't know what
drove him in to sit in the restaurant
so what kind of states can your agents
be there is going to be two states of
the world here which is uh which one is
a better restaurant
and that's what I'm trying to learn
so it's one of the things we're going to
simplify for all the talk we're only
going to have two states of the world
this is true or false
signal
can observe decisions of others which
are guesses about the states they don't
have beliefs about
yes
yeah the state I'm going to reserve that
word for the state of the world and
they're going to have beliefs about what
the state of the world is so we're going
to formalize all that stuff information
sets but the agent doesn't have a
separate state right agent no agent has
beliefs
conditional on everything I've seen what
I think the state of the world is what
is the probability that the Chinese
restaurants better here
there is a universal State and you get a
signal and I'm not going to use the word
state to represent me signal so let's
just just in third terminology the state
is global but you have local signals so
the agents don't have a state
so let's work for realization and what's
so what's interesting about this model
it's pretty easy to see from a
realization let's say agent one gets a
signal saying the Chinese restaurants
better so that agent is going to choose
the Chinese restaurant
let's say agent two gets the same signal
so that agent also chooses a Chinese
restaurant
now agent three gets a signal that says
Indian restaurants better but it but
agent three also sees these two guys
probably had signals in Chinese those
signals probably
two of those is the world is stronger
than one of mine so I should go to the
Chinese despite my signal
so the next person who comes in this
person doesn't see this signal say
Indian so the next person who comes in
only sees signals saying decisions say
in Chinese so even if the majority of
signals are Indian right even if the
true state is the Indian ones better the
you've heard it on the wrong State
you've heard it understood that might be
right or might be wrong right
and and why why this formulation because
it's classical there's this classical
idea in economics called wisdom of
crowds that goes back to the 1700s which
is sort of like if you want to make
decisions if you put in a lot of uh and
everybody has some information if you
pull it all together you're going to do
better
and the original application comes from
condorces saying you should decide if
people are guilty or Innocent by jury
and why buy jewelry so you can assemble
a bunch of signals and therefore you get
a better on average guess and there's
also in Gallatin's famous uh State Fair
story where he was in a state fair and
he asked everybody to guess the weight
of a bull and the average gas was better
than than almost all gases
so this idea that there's wisdom in the
crowds and therefore if you combine all
these signals you should be able to do
better than any individual does
and and and the argument in the in the
classical 1992 papers is that this kind
of wisdom goes away if you're not
actually combining signals directly but
you're just observing other people and
trying to make guesses about it right
and what do I mean this wisdom goes away
it means that the probability of making
a bad decision stays bounded away from
zero as then grows right you don't get a
central limit theorem convergence as
that grows you should be converting if
you're if you're combining signals since
you're not combining signals you're just
learning infern based on actions you
don't get this and we're going to call
this failure of asymptotic learning
because we're going to carry in the
limit as that grows you're not learning
the true state
uh the next paper that I want to jump to
which is a follow-up paper is a space
this is a chronometrical paper by Smith
and Sorensen it says
okay so let's think about the role of
signals in the story here a little bit
and
and what Smith and Sorensen does and
this is a simplified version of their
paper so let's say there's still two
states of the world but our signals are
drawn from two different distributions
F0 or F1 depending on what the true
state of the world is but they're no
longer uh just go here go there but
they're more complex the information
people have is more complex
and and the key uh object here in the
result is called the private belief and
what is a private belief is your belief
that is about the state given the signal
so you do a Bayesian computation here
and you say given the signal this is
what I think is a belief the status one
now if you look at these private beliefs
you can compute what I'm going to call P
under bar and P over bar and P over bar
is the worst possible belief you could
have just based on your signal if you
over bar is the best possible belief you
could have based on your signal if these
are bounded away from zero and one I'm
going to say this private lists are
bounded right so the signals are not
that strong you there's no signals out
there that are super strong and if they
go to zero and one I say the beliefs are
unbounded
you'll notice that I cheated a little
and there's a case here this could be
zero and this could be circular less
than one for example I'm going to ignore
that case because that's kind of like a
more complicated Edge case and I'm just
gonna consider these two cases of
bounded and unbounded in the stock
and the key result in Smith and sorry
said is that if profitability are
bounded then uh that story from
Pictionary from Welsh holds and there
are some productive learning fails but
if private beliefs are unbounded if
there exists strong signals out there
then asymptotic learning actually
succeeds and you actually get to full
learning so the story invictions falls
through and and so just to make sure
that we understand this idea of private
belief what is it what does it work
you can think of the private belief
being this Bayesian computation which
really wants to use the base row with
one plus and you do the ratio of
densities if the distributions have
densities
and if you see like if the ratio of
densities goes from zero to Infinity
that's unbounded and one easy example
that's going to happen that has this
property is if the state is is either a
normal distribution if either the
signals are coming from a normal would
mean zero or normal with mean one with
the same standard deviation
and you're trying to figure out which
one it is which which normal
distribution is generating the signals
and you can see that as the as the
signals go this way they become really
strong signals in favor of the set of
zero and the signals go this way they
become really strong signals in favor of
the status one so that's one example of
like what unbounded beliefs means
and so that's kind of like the
state-of-the-art results before our
paper and let me show you how uh Smith
and Sorensen proved this because it's
it's a really nice argument that we're
going to use some of this and we're
going to contrast so what's the argument
there
uh this method is called the Martingale
approach I'm calling it The Martingale
approach and here's how the proof works
at a high level so defined is not so so
we defined as the private belief which
is the belief based on the nerve signal
now the counterpart is a social belief
what do you believe about the world
based on all the decisions but not your
signal
so now since everybody observes
everything before everybody observes all
the actions before the sequence of
decisions defines the filtration and
what does that mean that means that all
the information Saturn asset with each
other right the the social belief
reagent and is contained in is something
that the agent n plus one can totally
guess right that's what a filtration
means and more than that the social
beliefs or Martingale with respect to
this to the filtration generated by this
now why are there Martingale because uh
if I'm agent then and I say I think the
state is one with probability 70 if I
guess what do I think the next guy
coming after me is going to believe
about the state my guest yes my best
guess is still 70 percent
Martingale
and then he can bring in the heavy
machinery from Martingale convergence
and Martin your convergence has almost
all sample paths converge that means if
you take any individual sample path it's
a convergence sequence
and
for you to converge you can't converge
to like 50 50. why didn't you convert to
50 50 because if you converts to 50 50
then you get a new signal that is making
you jump in your decision that can't be
a convergent sequence
that means this if it was convergent to
50 50 private beliefs would still be
bringing too much information which
would buy like convergence so
convergence means these are going
somewhere where sub where they are not
informative anymore
so if you have unbounded private beliefs
the only place you can convert to zero
and one so the
because otherwise you'd get a signal
that will be strong enough to move your
way and once you bring in rationality
you can't converge to a hundred percent
wrong thing and then you get full
learning and with pride with boundary
beliefs the learning gets stuck away
from zero one because once you get to
like I believe that say 95 correct you
can't get signals that are strong enough
to move you away from there
so that's kind of the state-of-the-art
approach from uh before our work
uh now let's head to our work
so we're interested in learning over
social networks right because all this
literature before assumes that everybody
observes the actions of everybody
right which is obviously an unrealistic
assumption and it's also the very hard
as a proof technique right because you
don't have a filtration if you don't
have this
and what we want to study in this paper
is can can we bring these ideas and
these results in social networks social
learning to complex social networks
and what do I mean by complex social
networks uh first thing you want to
allow is like sort of like deterministic
graphs right the network is some sort of
complicated graph but actually I want to
go beyond that I want to go to some sort
of like complex random graphs
and why do I want to do complex random
graphs because I want to be made I want
to be able to make claims about things
like oh people only know about their
local neighborhood right so maybe you
know exactly who your neighbors are but
you only have a belief about the other
people's neighborhoods right what is the
overall social network topology right so
you have a belief but you don't have
exact information and this is going to
allow some really interesting
uh estimation problems to emerge
because imagine like I observe that Sean
chose action one and I as observed the
Christina chose action zero now I need
to make a guess if Sean made that
decision independent of Christina after
observing Christina or maybe he didn't
observe Christina but both of them
observed kimon so I need to sort of like
start making these guesses and that
makes the the problem a lot harder and
the decisions observed change my belief
about what the network structure is
so that's why we need to do to add like
complex random grass here to make the
story
more interesting I do
so now let's get to the model questions
before I get to the bottle
yeah
the keywords that you mentioned
algorithms on um
so uh belief propagation is is is an
algorithm for you to find uh
I I don't think it's all that related
right it's not it's like an algorithm
where you do so this myopic belief
sharing it sends my beliefs
so you get the beliefs what the
probabilities uh whatever you get yeah
papers and then I also send my message
yeah
oh yeah I love to hear your thoughts uh
I I okay look here thinking on the spot
I don't know of a connection
but I'd love to hear your thoughts if
you think there's a connection yeah let
me just uh typically for message passing
the sort of the update of the messages
it's a simple linear rule but here he
assumes that the agents are fully
rational and because our food you
actually on the update could be actually
30 that sort of right like they have to
solve an healthy heart problem to decide
what's the Inner Circle okay thank you
appreciate it yeah and let me add a
formal comment so I'm assuming these
agents are superhuman right they can
solve these and be hard from these
estimation problems and that's on
purpose and why why do I mean that's on
purpose because before this paper all
the learning networks paper assume very
myopic rules of behavior right because
the idea is like learning basic learning
networks is not attractable probably
don't know how to analyze because you
can't solve these estimation problems
you don't know how to do it and the the
point of the paper here is you actually
even if you can't fully understand what
an individual's decision optimal
decision would be we can still make
claims about the overall uh long-term
outcomes we can still make limit claims
that's going to be the theme of the
presentation here and it's sort of like
and I am fully aware that I'm putting a
lot of uh rationality assumption into my
agents but that's on purpose I'd like to
understand the sort of like ideal limit
if people are rational what would happen
because it's a strong contrast to
everything that was in the literature
before
um so now uh state of the world I'm
going to keep it simple to stay it's
equally likely
the equally likely doesn't really bite
but the two states uh I mean there's you
need to be a little bit careful with
extension because of the issues of like
uh the boundary versus unbounded so
we're gonna keep we're going to keep as
these things as simple as we can and the
decision we're also going to keep super
simple everybody guesses the state
everybody agent Agents come in sequence
and they choose zero one and if they
guessed right they get a dollar if they
guess wrong they get zero
uh everybody's incentive is just to
guess what the state is so we're keeping
these things super simple as simple as
we can signals we're going to follow
Smith and Sorensen and say everybody has
an IAD private signal conditional on the
state and the signals generated by F0
if the set is zero and F1 if the state
is one and this pair of distributions
what I call the signal structure
and now uh The Social Network
here's where the Innovation comes in
each agent has a neighborhood which is a
subset of people who have acted in the
past and you can observe all the
decisions for agents in your in your
neighborhood
this neighborhood is private information
only you know the realization is going
to be generated According to some
distribution qn
and and the qn the distribution is
common knowledge and there's one
important assumption that we make here
which is that these distributions are
generated independently so the
neighborhoods so so this is super
General with the exception of this
assumption right so this is like I'm I'm
not putting any structure whatsoever on
what the distributions are of of
neighborhoods but I am making an
independence assumption uh we have a
paper uh that I wrote with Evan settler
a few years after this one that we
generalize this to more to like
correlate the neighborhood and I'll
comment on that later on but this is an
important assumption here
for the results but other than that it's
like a very general Network topology and
this is common knowledge everybody knows
the net the the stochastic process that
generates the neighborhoods but
everybody Only Knows their own local
neighborhood
so you have uh prior informations that
which is your signal your neighborhood
and all the actions in your neighborhood
and what I'm going to call a social
network or an instance of my model is a
signal structure and an electric
topology and I want to understand can I
make claims about learning versus
non-learning in these settings
so um just as an example you can imagine
that like signals come from some
distribution and there's some
distribution over neighborhoods right
either empty or observe the last Sky
observe everybody and once you have a
let me just sort of like go quickly once
you have a realization this agent here
has a signal and this agent observes the
stuff and this agent knows and if this
agent needs to guess if this person
chose one independently of these or
after observing these then that makes a
big difference yes
clarification are the things directed or
Underground
it's a directed graph because agents are
going to come in order
I'm so I'm I'm one thing that I'm not
making endogenous year is the timing of
your decision making so the timing that
you make a decision is exogenous
and that voice is the thing to be
directed right because you can all
observe actions that happen before you
made a decision so everybody everybody
makes a decision only once there's a
there's another really interesting
literature that came after my uh mainly
by America moves from Caltech where his
his study models where you can make a
bunch of decisions over time and Philips
truck has done some work on this so it's
really fascinating papers but in this
paper here everybody makes one decision
and they're gone
so what is the solution concept here
we're going to try to keep this as
rational as possible so a strategy is
just a mapping from your information set
to zero one
so it's a pure strategy of the random no
need to randomize your uh a strategy
profile is a sequence of agent
strategies and once you choose a
strategy profile you get a probability
measure over actions right so this
defines a probability like the decisions
become a stochastic process once you
define a strategy
and we're going to say that agents are
playing a perfect Beijing equilibrium if
they're choosing the optimal thing given
the information set assuming everybody
else is playing the same equilibrium so
very standard so the notion of perfect
Beijing equilibrium is usually a more
complicated definition in our model
because everybody acts once it's it's
the way the structure of the model it's
pretty simple it's just everybody is
fully rational and makes the best
decision giving everything they know
and the question that we want to know is
it for a given equilibrium whether the
decisions are converting to the correct
thing whether whether the wisdom of the
crowd's idea holds or not
okay
so what are some of the things that make
Bayesian learning networks hard to
analyze one is you don't have the kind
of monotonicity you might want and it
might help you a lot so look at this
network here this guy chose zero these
three tools one and this guy chose one
now keep all the signals constant
except for this one let's flip the
signal here to make this guy a one
it's perfectly plausible that this one
switches from one to zero this one
switches in the opposite direction
now why can't this switch in the
opposite direction because when these
guys are actually one despite seeing a
zero that's a really strong signal that
the status one now when these guys are
choosing one because they're caught in
this one that's a much weaker signal
favor set one
so even though you switch this from zero
to one this guy's social belief went in
the other way
so this guy might shoot might switch
from one to zero so you don't get the
kind of monotonicity that would be super
helpful the kind of stuff that Ali was
using left and right yesterday and now
um less can be more so there's another
kind of monotonicity you don't have
which is I can I can remove some Edge
and I can make this guy better off
because uh it's possible that like
there's too many there's too much too
many people putting too much weight on
the sky here right
so am I it's not the case that like a
complete network is the best one for
money
so now uh any questions before I get to
our approach to how what do we actually
do
so okay all right so here's here's
our contribution to to actually solve
the model instead of using a marting you
approach we're going to use what I call
an improvement function of course
and think think of an agent and
observing only one neighbor so agent n
the neighborhood of agent that is just B
now in equilibrium I can make the
following claim agent 10 is better off
than hmd
why can I make this time that agent 10
is better off than hmb agent 10 has a
very simple heuristic that h m can use
which is copy Agent B do whatever they
do
and that would give agent 10 the
expected utility equal to this right
remember I assume that the probability
is a good expected
by putting the utility zero and one
now
um if agent then is choosing to
disregard the action of Agent B I'm
doing something different they must have
strong information that that's a better
thing to do
so they have they can do better
so I might be able to use this to make
an argument that if you're observing hmb
you can do better than hmb here this
very simple argument I just used that we
can have filed it to actually get
somewhere useful I need to make this in
Apollo District
so I could just could you repeat the
last point if You observe HP you can do
better than HIV or you can do better
than not observing If You observe hmb
you can do weekly better than agency
because you have a heuristic available
to you which is I caught the agency
and if you're choosing not to do that in
equilibrium you're expected utility must
be higher and this is your expected
utility of of quality agency
so this is a key idea we're going to
build on this quite a bit
well thank you for talking to that we
would like to make this a a strict and
it bother to write somehow quantify the
gains of information you have over an
agent to observe
and if you do maybe we can build this
turn doesn't talk you have enough
solution maybe we can use a liver
control theory so say we can drive the
system to the right place here
so that's going to be the technique that
we use in script
so let's start with the case Where You
observe one person You observe one
person I actually know how you should
decide there that case is easier to
calculate and the optimal thing to do is
if your private belief is somewhere in
the middle of some two thresholds it's
like it's not a very strong private
belief I copy what I see right if if I
don't really have a strong private
signal about what the state is I just
populated but if I have a strong private
signal I ignore what hmb did and I call
I do something else so if I have a very
strong signal the state is 0 I to zero
if I have a strong signal the state is
one I chose one and if if I'm
indifferent if I'm kind of indifferent I
choose to copy
yes
they're lower and upper thresholds yeah
we have a specific yeah that's going to
come in this point here a couple bullet
points on the row is going to be I can
compute them they're based on they're
easy to compute based on the conditional
probability of the state being correct
uh under the status one and under the
set is zero so there I I have false form
solutions for them so there is no no
possibility that it goes into really the
low obstruction
[Music]
is that right so you're indifferent
between the two options if you're right
at the threshold
you're indifferent so I'm saying that if
you're not indifferent if you're not
branded address you need to do it this
way if you're in a threshold you can if
you're in this threshold you can just
between this and this and if you're a
distraction you can just do this
so there's multiple reproducted
so the argument that I was making before
is that there should be a strict
Improvement if there is a positive
chance that your decision is different
than agent B's
so to get stronger to get strict
Improvement what do I need I need a
private signals to be unbounded why do I
need a private ticket why is this
private signal is equivalent of private
signals being about I need for any
thresholds that I get and these
thresholds are strictly between zero and
one
then I always have some probability of
having a a private signal above this and
a positive probability of getting a
signal below this
so if the private signals are unbounded
then I do get a strict Improvement here
and these thresholds as I was mentioning
are are a function of a two-dimensional
state
they're a function of the probability of
the state is one the pro the probability
agent being made or I think given the
set of zero and the probability of the
Agent B made the right thing given the
state is one so given if I have these
two numbers here and this is a fully
rational model so I can compute these
things in expectation right I can
pretend these guys are super rational
computers and they can calculate these
things I can use that to determine these
thresholds
um so the tricky thing here is that the
state's face is two-dimensional now one
so together function I really need a
strict Improvement that applies for all
values right so all values that lead to
the same probability of x b equals Theta
right which I can simplify as this plus
this equals a constant I need a uniform
gain over all of those so that's where
some of the technicality comes in
I'm going to skip the technicality
uh but yeah but there's like at least 10
pages in the paper on this stuff is
actually constructing a function Z it's
just saying that you actually can get
this strict Improvement that is uniform
so a lot of the math is hidden under
here which is saying there is just a
function Z and this function Z is
strictly bigger than than the identity
for every number below one such that if
You observe the action of Agent B you
can do strictly better than H and B by
this function right this tells you like
if I observe keymon and keymon is 80
right the Z function say then I can do
at least 82 percent right
and I cannot construct something like
this if the private beliefs are bounded
so this is going to be the same
distinction in a way of Smith Insurance
and it's coming from a different reason
here but it's forming the same
distinction
and
and if you're if you are familiar with
control theory Z of alpha minus Alpha is
function here right
this is going to be a lapino function
this means the system is going to have
to go to one
if
everybody's observing one person so here
is a corollary that comes immediately
from this Lemma if everybody observes
the guy before them
then you get learning if and only if
private Bliss are bounded because if you
have a lapino function if and only if
private beliefs are unbounded
function is there a standard way to
construct it or yes
[Music]
no it's not unique it's I mean we spend
a bunch of pages on the paper just
constructing one oh you need is a
construct one yeah I know but it's a
standard way to construct it that's a
method to constructed or it's trial and
error basically just like no it's sort
of like we I mean the key part here is
is you need to write find the worst
possible situation like given that the
probability of being equals Theta
there's all these possible possibilities
you need to sort of like look at what
the worst possible is and put it in
prison and use that as your Z
so it's kind of like we're doing the
basement
no it's a good time doing a lot of
baseballs it's just this comes out of
like working hard
that's why I'm asking no standard way to
contract it yeah no no so it's it comes
straight from the basement okay but yeah
so it takes a little bit of work to get
to the right but the one that works but
then then we get one and it says here we
already have a result that's new in the
literature which is If You observe just
a guy before you rather than everybody
before you you have this private beliefs
for words
which is a very specific Network right I
was pitching that I want to do this in
complex social networks not on YouTube
the last guy right so now let's go let's
try to generalize this to other networks
now instead of uh Agent B being a
Singleton and if in agents uh and net
neighborhood now let's say the
neighborhood contains B
but there's more people there
none of men argue the same Z function
still applies
and how can I argue the same zip
function supplies I'm going to do the
same thing I did before which is I'm
going to build a heuristic and say that
heuristic is available and the heuristic
gives me this
and in equilibrium you can do better
than any heuristic you have right so if
you're super rational or you can do
better than any of the heuristics all I
need to do is build a heuristic
calculate the value of the heuristic and
that serves as a benchmark for me and
the heuristic is pretty simple throw
away all the other decisions in your in
your neighborhood just choose bees and
then make the optimal decision based on
your signal in that decision right you
have all these decisions there one
option you have available is toss
everything right keep on
and if you toss everything away keep one
you get this you get this so in
equilibrium you need to be doing better
than this
so since all I want to do
so with complex neighborhoods once I
have a bunch of Agents I have no idea
how to characterize equilibrium
strategies so if if everybody upstairs
one person I can do an exact calculation
of what each person should be doing but
once you're observing two people I don't
know how to do that because the
correlation could be really complicated
but I don't need to the story in the
paper is like all I need to do is sort
of like bound the quality of decisions
and if I can bound the following
decisions I can make claims about what
happens in more General Networks
so if you if you think for what this
implies it implies that if lines exist
in the network for all agents and this
is very vague and not formally yet but
I'll formalize in the next slide but if
the notion is if ever agent can find a
line backwards then you can get learning
just like before right you don't need
you don't need the agents will be on the
line you need the lines to exist in the
graph topology
so you sort of
equipment become calculated but yes I'm
very I'm very personally using that that
these agents can do better than that
this is important no no so I mean maybe
if they did optimally they actually
wanted to converge
they were so that's the theorem of the
paper
uh under the conditions that I get
learning if they do the outro thing they
will converge
I think what she's saying is that if the
online network is
easyness
then I think
it is
no what I'm saying is
you sort of has this meta theorem that
if you have any greedy strategy which
actually gives you learning then the
optimal strategy which we have no idea
how to calculate but we know Exist by
abstract nonsense must also learn so I
can't make that statement about the
overall scene the the statements is
about an individual agent an agent in
the network has a strategy
and I can and if the agent can do better
than that strategy and if all I'm
keeping track are these probabilities of
correctness
uh the only thing that better decision
making can do is push those push and
individual's decision up
it's perfectly plausible there's nothing
here that disproves the following fact
if agent end does better that could be
worse for agent 10 plus one
but all the bounds will still hold so
I'm not making any claims that like
making one agent better off will make
future agents better off
it's a little subtle here but the
argument is is there is a lower bound
that I can obtain here as a function of
your position in the line
so let me let me show the line argument
a little bit more formally
so suppose you have a deterministic
network this is your graph
everybody
you trace back the longest line you can
and count how many agents aside so this
guy has a line of size five one two
three four five
so I can how well can I say how how good
is the decision of agent 8 is at least Z
of Z of Z of Z of Z of Z of the prior
and I use Z five times because the
Elevate is five so I can bound the
quality of the the decisions as as a
function of how long the lines are
sorry
[Music]
yeah so the bound is based on the path
where you can
yeah it's not an exponent it's a
composition thing yeah I applied a
function the Improvement function uh
10 times it's already the end position
here but let's think about the converse
now let's assume if this limit was
Infinity then by the left argument I
learned if this limit doesn't go to
Infinity then line for valence is finite
which means there's a sequence there's a
subsequence here that converges to a
finite number and anybody in that
subsequence can only be pointed to the
first few guys so the learning cannot
happen for those guys so this turns out
to be an exact characterization for
phone Networks
it requires a little bit of thinking to
see the converse but it follows from
this
now what if I what if I go to graphs can
I can can I expand the same idea to like
random graphs my argument is going to be
yes the same characterization Works in
random graphs so it does have to be a
little bit more careful with the
definitions here which is now not
exactly about the lines
but I need the the largest element in
your neighborhood to be converged into
Infinity in probability
so if I the the sufficient statistic
here is everybody has this stochastic
neighborhood pick the largest element I
want that guy in probability to be going
to Infinity so as an grows large the
largest uh the the largest element is
always it gets bigger than any k
uh the agent director last so these
agents act in a sequence of efficient
100 uh the the key sufficient statistic
here to make this Frame is like if this
agent 100 could observe agent 90 that's
the largest one that one could observe
so I can ignore the early agents right
because you can imagine like the early
agents don't really matter here because
they didn't have a lot of signals in
them
and the converse of this is that I have
excessively influential agents which is
there exists an infinite number of
Agents with probability bound uniformly
bounded away from zero observe only the
excessive influence our agent and this
notion of expanding observations is
equivalent to not their non-existing
excessively influential agents so it's
it's not hard to show The Following
result that if if the network topology
does not have this condition then no
equilibrium can learn because it's just
a signal counting argument that people
who are not who don't who don't satisfy
this limit they're not going to have
enough signals to learn
as and growth but the the cool result is
that is the other way which is if you
haven't bounded private beliefs and you
have expanded observations then you do
learn
because this is the right
stochastic Network generalization of the
notion of you have long paths
but uh that's I think is is the most
interesting result in the paper there's
several other results that I'll discuss
but I I personally this is my favorite
result in the paper
and it sort of says that if you have
these unbounded private beliefs like
spending observations is the exact
correct characterization
of uh whether learning happens or not
so one thing to think about is consider
the following Network topology where
everybody observes agent one and the
agent right before them
so most of the myopic models in the
literature will tell you that this this
is a terrible Network for learning right
everybody observes two decisions right
one decision that is good one that's not
very good
and you're not going to be able there's
some confounding going on there right so
because on this because there's this
agent one who's influencing everybody
you're gonna end up somewhere bad
this does not happen in uh
in a Bayesian model in a Bayesian model
people learn to ignore each and one
so an implicit assumption here is I know
to identify who is the agent one right
so I know who I'm focusing on who has
good information and this issue that I
know how to identify really becomes key
in my follow-up paper with Evan on
correlated neighborhoods because
learning to identify becomes harder
uh so the way I interpret this result is
that synthetic learning is super robust
if you have unbounded private beliefs
right really the networks for this fail
are really like very broken networks in
a way there's no way the learning could
happen just by signal count energy
now um
what happens if you have bound I believe
so this is the kind of the original
setting the bhw setting where you have
imagine you have two or three or four
signals you have a finite number of
signals and and this whole literature
started that learning doesn't happen
there
so now the first result that I have for
here is I'm going to construct a set of
networks where you do get learning then
the way it's defined in the paper is
more complicated and more General than
this but I think this is easier to
understand
so imagine I definitely need to explain
the observations because if I don't have
this I can rule out learning I'm going
to add two things here and they seem a
little contradictory I'm going to add
some people hosting nothing and some
people who say everything foreign
but these are uniformly Epsilon away so
there's a lot this is a number of these
guys in the network and there's a very
few of these in the net so this might
seem crazy right how can this help
right imagine these guys with knowing
for who can't observe anything imagine
these guys who can observe everything
and I'm going to argue here that dentist
if you have a Network that has these
kinds of properties then learning always
happens
so so to prove this result we're going
to combine the technique in our work of
expanding observations and and doing
these Improvement paths with the
technique of martingales so let's let's
walk through the argument so uninformed
agents they act based on their signals
only right they don't have anything else
so they're bringing in
sufficient information to the network
and there's infinitely many of them so
you're going to get infinite and many
signals in the network
now the aggregators they can learn the
state
and how do they how can they learn to
stay this is kind of like
it's it might be tricky because they
don't know exactly who is making these
decisions right they don't know
but by seeing that people chose one when
everybody else chose zero you know that
that's very likely somebody who had uh
who is an uninformed agent
and you can sort of like think of
accounting how frequently did they show
up did they show up consistent with the
state being one or did they show up
consistent with the state being zero so
you can count how many people did the
wrong thing in a way right did the
opposite of their previous guy and based
on that you can you can sort of guess
and the proof here really relies on the
Martingale argument very similar to the
old paper and that's why I assume that
everybody observes everything else you
don't need as I mentioned you can relax
there's a little but you do need this
sort of structure in there
and once these guys know enough there's
enough of them in the network because
assuming everybody has at least an
absolute probability of being one of
these guys who knows exactly what the
state of the world is that the
information paths from them spread to
everybody else
and one thing that might be tricky is
what does it mean spread for everybody
else don't you have infinite in many
guys who
who don't know what the state is
I'm saying sure yes but the probability
that you're one of these guys goes to
zero
so uh so by assuming this this thing
here I can still allow for the
probability of these guys to go to zero
and if the probability of these guys
wasn't going to zero I'll be violating
explain the observations
so one way to say this is to say in the
unbounded private beliefs
would you ask questions
so one way to say this is to say when
you have unbounded private beliefs some
signals don't get suppressed because
they are strong enough that they can get
suppressed here since you have bounded
by that beliefs you have this uninformed
agents who don't suppress their signals
because they don't see anything else
yeah they also have to see those that's
part of the answer but the other answer
is that it's going to become more clear
in the next slide I also need some guys
to be able to observe enough of them
so to make to make this right because
now let me show you the next slide where
your argument fails because now if I had
exactly this but now let's say that I
have a constant bound down with the size
of our necklace
again I can't get learning with private
peace we talk about with our with the
founder privacy
so I do need some agents that observe
more and more people
so if I
what I'm saying
so this the implication here is you need
aggregators for learning there's one
caveat here that I strengthen my network
I put a network assumption here and a
network assumption that I had expanded
observation was this guy was going to
Infinity in probability now here I'm
strengthening this so this guy goes to
Infinity almost shortly
so there's a stronger assumption here
and one and and why do I need this
assumption here first of all I don't
know if I need this assumption uh this
is what I was able to prove it's
possible that you could get this but the
reason I the reason I use this
assumption here in my proof is that
since the largest guy goes to Infinity
almost surely you always have one guy in
your neighborhood who's very high so
you're always observing
um
somebody who has a very strong signal
sorry somebody has a very strong social
signal so that means like you you this
kind of stops people from
from heavy and informed decisions right
so this also stops the only from maybe
it's not so let me take it back because
when I put this assumption I'm also
stopping
um
the uninformed people from being there
right because the maximum guy is
converging over shortlet infinity so
this also blocks that inform people from
existing
but there is a there is definitely an
open question here which is if I weak so
the if I weaken this to improbability
then this becomes expanded observations
which I know is a minimal condition for
learning uh can I kind of rule out
learning here
I don't know that's an open question
but my the way I think about this is
that
when you have when you have private
beliefs that are bounded you can't you
can't just sort of like look at one guy
and learn from them you kind of have to
look from a large set of people and try
to learn from them so you need in a way
there's a distinction between the sort
of like Improvement type learning where
I learned from one person and my signal
versus this Martingale style learning
where I'm learning from a lot of people
plus my signal
and in a way I feel that literature is
sort of like missing more taking more
you could think of other heuristics you
could use to sort of like make claims
about this is as hard because once you
start once you start putting a bunch of
agents in here and you and and there
could be a lot of information in there
and but it's hard to parse how much
information there is because you don't
know exactly the correlation structure
could be very complicated
this does not rule out what I mean by
saying right like because here it seems
like the uninformed agents are Vanishing
like yeah here here you can't have
uninformed agents because everybody has
a high name
so the the the neighborhood the maximum
element in every neighborhood is
converging
to Infinity I'm not sure
but yeah there's definitely a gap in our
knowledge about what happens in this
case
But but so so the interpretation here is
subject to a uh an asterisk
my interpretation
so let me just comment on a couple of
follow-up papers that I wrote with Evan
Sadler on this problem uh Evan was a PhD
student at NYU with me and now he's an
assistant professor at Columbia of
economics
and um and the first paper is like let's
generalize the networks so that you
don't have this Independence assumption
and and the question is the the results
kind of hold and the answer is not
really is that you can get this so
there's two interesting Stakes there one
is that there's a failure there that's
worse than the failure of asymptotic
learning like uh because with the
minding your arguments you always get to
at least as good an information decision
as if you had a very strong signal
it's possible that those strong signals
are not there and once you have
correlated Network you even fail in this
position
and the issue that comes up is that this
Improvement becomes harder because I I
not only need to point to somebody when
expectation is good I need to point to
somebody that given everything I know is
good so I need to sort of like figure
out who I want to improve from
so there's a there's a whole Machinery
that we had to build for this paper to
sort of like extend the Improvement
principle to General networks and it's
it's not as clean the results because
it's very hard to characterize this
notion of uh which
uh which neighbor which uh agent I
should be looking at given everything I
know to try to improve on and we also
had a paper that extends this paper to
uh if you have diverse preferences like
if people have preferences for being
correct and preferences for choosing
action one and those are diverse in the
network
and the argument there is are like the
marketing style aggregation is actually
positively affected by this because this
brings more signals into here
but Improvement principles actually gets
hurt because you're learning from One
agent and that decision is now noisier
because you don't really know that the
preferences of the person you're copying
all right so um just some uh concluding
thoughts so the prior state of the art
on on display on this model and this
problem was based on Martin your
converters it's a really powerful hammer
but it requires this filtration which
makes it like far from an Ideal tool for
networks because you need you need
information sets to be nested which is
pretty unreasonable in Networks
and our paper propose an alternative
approach based on this Improvement
heuristic
and the idea is it's an easy heuristic
to characterize in an equilibrium agents
need to be doing better than this and
this gives us a lot and it actually
gives us a full characterization of what
happens in the unbounded private beliefs
case
and it gives some progress on the
boundary Bliss case but not a full
characterization
and I just want to conclude by saying
this paper is now
what 14 years since I put it out on on
the web and 11 years since it came out
in the journal uh but there's been a lot
of written work that followed up mine I
know many people here have worked on
this problem I know I mean has worked
and optimon has worked and Ali and
nazarash have worked many people have
worked on this problem and have done
really interesting work but I want to
highlight two papers that I personally
think are awesome
and I'm not citing all the papers I'm
just citing two papers that I think are
people really should know one is by uh
myself
and it came out in econometric I know
seven years ago and it's it's it does a
similar thing as mine papers and like it
does a pretty full characterization of
what happens but assuming that agents
can act over and over and over again
and it and it's very hard because then
agents are strategic in their decisions
because you might want to make a bad
decision today to help you tomorrow but
they're able to show that the myopic one
is a good approximation it's a really
beautiful very complicated paper I mean
the the fact that these are
mathematicians really comes out and and
the other one is his favorite by Dr and
here that won the best paper to see last
year and this paper does the following
instead of looking at General signal
structures it looks suggestion and says
once I restrict the questions I can do
exact computations of how much learning
you have and you can make like you can
say this thing the social signal is
worth 1.3 private signals and therefore
they're able to do a much more like
exact analysis than I can because
gaussian brings a lot of tructibility
it's really it's really nice paper too
so um
better thank you very much
[Applause]
so
so on so I considered gaussians
unbounded so what was said to do I
thought you were you sort of killed the
unbounded problems so why was yeah
they're able to so a lot of papers that
came out are trying to understand rights
of learning and and I think one of the
key papers is that like you learn a lot
from one or two generations and you
learn almost nothing after
so my technique doesn't say a lot about
rates it does a lower bound and rate
it's not a very good lower bound and
this one is able to tell you exact
bounds because by going to gaussians
they're able to they're they're no
longer have to bounce things but they
can make statements about oh this
decision is worth that many signals
so I was wondering if you know some
other papers who have used this sort of
improvement heuristic to study other
sort of non-marching game
settings
so do you know if this is I mean I've
seen other papers
using the Improvement heuristic in this
kind of context is that what I mean yes
I I am I've come across them I can't
really tell you at the top of my head
thanks
I mean it is one of the standard tools
in the toolkit now a lot of people have
used that after my favorites
foreign
I think I might have missed something
when you went from uh like a known
deterministic graph to the stochastic
one
um
like I think I followed the the
deterministic graph like you just need
to find a path
um but in the stochastic setting
um even if there was some uh like path
that existed with high probability but
but you as an agent when you see your
neighborhood you don't know where the
path is right so you wouldn't know which
one of the uh neighbors to kind of Base
your estimate often so how do you handle
that or once so the way we handle that
is really I don't need to know the paths
all I need to do is I can use the
probability or characters in sufficient
statistic and if I have a high
probability of observing you I have a
high probability of being able to
observe you so there's like an
expectation over so the the thing that I
iterate over and over is like an
expectation over Z
so it becomes I I definitely skip some
steps there
but it is it is not it is a non-trivial
step the there is an on Triple step
which is instead of just sort of like
doing Z on Z on Z on Z like on a
deterministic graph you can do you have
to do this expectation there every other
step isn't like there's a high
probability here that you can observe
somebody high so I can I can use that to
bound so that serves as a leopard
function but there's also like uh I have
to know the distribution of your your
network and your yeah so the the
Assumption here is the distributions are
common knowledge
all the distributions of all the
neighborhoods are common knowledge and
you use that in your computation
computation of disease or
uh no it doesn't show up in a
computation of disease does it comes
from the observing energy
from the update role yeah but uh but it
shows up in the
it shows up when you apply it right the
laptop type application
all right very good thank you so much
[Applause]
foreign